la aprobación forzada de la Reforma de
pensiones de Manuel macron en la
asamblea nacional tuvo su primera
respuesta legislativa este viernes con
la presentación de dos mociones de
censura contra el gobierno de Elizabeth
burner el partido de derechas radical
reagrupación nacional depositó la suya
propia y el grupo de parlamentarios
independientes y de ultramar liot
presentó otra respaldada por la unión de
izquierdas nupes de acuerdo con el
reglamento de la asamblea nacional una
moción de censura a la que cuente con
más signatarios será votada en el
hemiciclo esto debería ocurrir a inicios
de la semana entrante recordemos esa
moción de censura tiene como objetivo
forzar la dimisión de la primera
ministra y de su gobierno su aprobación
no es muy probable porque los grupos de
izquierda ultraderecha y los
independientes suman unos 262 votos y se
requieren al menos 287 para que esa
petición sea aprobada no hay otra
solución entonces que sumar al menos 25
di tados del partido de derecha los
republicanos algunos de ellos han
expresado públicamente que no descartan
votar la moción pero no existe un
compromiso sólido en ese sentido
mientras las manifestaciones huelgas
protestas y bloqueos prosiguen este
viernes con llamados a mantener la
presión durante el fin de